&gt;&gt; Hi, I'm Miriam. &gt;&gt; And, I'm Julie and we're your instructors for College
Algebra, Animals, Architecture and Innovation. &gt;&gt; You'll be seeing a lot of our
hands throughout the course, but we thought we would show you our faces too, so
you could get to know us better. &gt;&gt; For you people out there, who don't think
you are math people, we're out here to prove you wrong. Recent research has
shown that students who have difficulties learning mathematics, have
difficulties not because they're not smart, but because often they've had bad
experiences learning mathematics. What's even better is that you can help your
brain grow through doing math. This course is designed to help you play around
with college algebra. Try to step out, make mistakes, try again, just get
involved with it. Research also shows that making mistakes helps with learning.
You're hear to learn about college algebra. We don't expect you to know
everything.
And you're not alone either, we have thousands of students all over the world
taking this course. Talking about math can actually help you learn it better and
the forum is a great place to do this. You can ask questions about things you
don't understand or even just about cool algebra related things. So that's
probably pretty different from other math classes you've taken before. It's
theme based and it focuses on inquiry learning which means that we help you
discover the mathematics on your own and show how it's relevant for your life.
We hope you enjoy the course. Let's get started.